we all remember when jesse smellet was
viciously attacked in chicago had a
noose placed around his neck just barely
summoned the fortitude to keep hold of
his subway sandwich during the assault
well three years later smilet's attacker
has finally been brought to justice
he did not take the news well
you are fined
25 000 which is the maximum fine
and you will spend the first 150 days of
your sentence in the cook county jail
and that will start today right here
right now do you have any questions
no i would just like to say to your
honor that i am
i am not
suicidal that's what i was practicing
i'm not suicidal okay i am not
suicidal i am innocent and i am not
suicidal
if i did this then it means that i stuck
my fist in the fears of black americans
in this country for over 400 years and
the fears of the lgbtq community your
honor i respect you and i respect the
jury but i did not do this and i am not
suicidal and if anything happens to me
when i go in there
i did not do it to myself and you must
all know that
i respect you your honor i respect your
decision
jail time
i am not suicidal okay
the most surprising part of the
sentencing was finding out that jesse
smallette has incriminating information
on the clintons that i'm not suicidal
was the cry of a man just waiting for
hillary to walk in with the pillow but
the next most surprising thing about the
sentencing was that smallett is going to
jail at all
i had just assumed that he'd get off the
hook like every other well-connected
politically correct leftist who plays
the right victim cards
but jesse will go to jail and he should
because his crime was not just against
himself
and his crime was not just against the
chicago pd
it was a crime against
half of this country a crime against
maga country which he defamed as a
racist lynch mob he perpetrated a fraud
on one half of this country about the
other half
it's the same fraud that the liberal
establishment perpetrates every day when
it calls us deplorable and irredeemable
jesse smellette just took it a little
bit further and made the mistake of
casting nigerian homosexuals to play
anti-gay white supremacists so he got
caught and despite repeated attempts by
the establishment to let him off the
hook now he's paying the price
good
justice for jesse means just a teensy
tiny little bitty bit of justice for the
rest of us too i'm michael knowles this
is the michael knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from grant denham
who says what a legend ethan was he
totally disagreed and never hid that he
hit hard with his arguments and although
i think he's wrong i respect him for
being able to simply express his views
listen to michael's views and at least
actually hear what michael said yes
thank you i really think if you missed
the show yesterday uh go tune into it i
had my friend ethan berman on ethan is a
true tried and true liberal democrat
from california but i wanted to bring
him on to just understand the left's
point on the parental rights and
education bill in florida the one
they're calling the don't say gay bill i
invited on a number of liberals pretty
prominent liberals some even not so
prominent liberals
none of them would come on
they were also they loved taking pot
shots on twitter or on their youtube
channels but none of them have the guts
to actually come on the show and discuss
the issue even though i'm a very nice
guy i'm not doing any gotchy games here
i wanted an elevated discussion to just
hear the best argument the other side
could make ethan gladly accepted the
invitation and did it and i give him a
lot of credit for coming on i think i
think we need a whole lot more of that
especially these days where there's just
so much disinformation there's so much
fake news there's someone everyone's
just playing the victim card i mean for
goodness sakes people people are getting
attacked leftist actors black gay actors
are getting attacked in the maga country
of the south side of chicago so we are
told you gotta you gotta protect
yourself folks okay your person your
community and your home which is why you
gotta check out ring right now go to
ring.com
knowles you know about the ring video
doorbell i've told you about it for
years did you know that ring makes an
alarm that's right a full-on
award-winning home security system it's
available with professional monitoring
when you subscribe best of all you can
install it yourself even i i'm not the
handiest guy in the world i need to hire
a team of contractors to screw in a
light bulb even i can install
ring i i know you've heard me talk about
that ring alarm well now i have got the
pro
the pro the ring alarm pro is where it
is at is it a it is a next level
security system cnet calls ring alarm
pro a giant leap for home security and
after using it i think they're
absolutely right ring alarm pro helps
protect the entire home and the wi-fi
that it runs on with ring alarm pro ring
combined a home security system with a
wi-fi router so this thing helps protect
your home and your network your physical
world and your digital world it's an
amazing product right now head on over
to ring.com
knowles gopro
be like me get that pro kit right now
ring dot com slash knowles k-w-l-e-s no
more amateur hour gopro ring.com
knowles
speaking of disinformation yesterday on
the show we covered this
very weird story about the bio labs in
ukraine or the bio labs that may or may
not exist initially we were told by
ukraine and by the fact checkers over at
politifact and snopes that there are no
foreign u.s run bio labs in ukraine this
after the russians accuse the united
states
of having these bio labs not only in
ukraine but in a lot of countries around
the world china came out and made the
same allegation so initially from the
united states and ukraine
you'd know there's no bio labs but the
language was very particular
ukraine had said in the kiev post
there's no
foreign bio labs but there might be
ukrainian bio labs that the americans
are very involved in right politifact
said there are no u.s run bio labs okay
well maybe the labs are run by the
ukrainians but we now know because of
the testimony of under secretary of
state for political affairs victoria
newland we now know there are bio labs
the united states helped to build the
bio labs the united states is still very
involved in the bio labs and they're
afraid that it's going to fall into
russian hands now so
so we know that the fact checks were
completely false
in terms of the actual existence of
these places with u.s involvement that's
now an established fact
so finally after a couple days
the
pentagon has responded to this they say
it's total malarkey
the russian accusations uh are absurd
they're laughable
and
you know in the words of my irish
catholic grandfather
a bunch of malarkey
there's nothing to it it's classic
russian propaganda and uh and uh i
wouldn't uh if i were you i wouldn't
give it uh
i wouldn't give it a drop of ink worth
worth paying attention to yeah but but
can you explain to us what has there
been any relationship between them we
are not
not
developing biological or chemical
weapons inside ukraine it's not
happening
now that that second part of his answer
to the reporter that's the part that
really raises eyebrows because on the
surface it sounds like it's just a flat
denial right no this is bogus it's not
true as he said in the first part it's
malarkey where have we heard that before
from our very honest president joe biden
yeah when i hear that word malarkey my
eyebrow goes up too but the second part
is the key here
because the reporter asks has there been
a relationship it seems the next part
will be between the u.s and ukraine in
these labs developing potential bile
either potential biological weapons or
other hazardous biological material that
may have nothing to do with any
intention of creating weapons and john
kirby there this pentagon spokesman cuts
him off and he says the united states
and ukraine the united states is not
developing biological weapons in ukraine
it's not happening this is very weird
phrasing
because he's using the present tense
obviously we're not doing really
anything in ukraine right now because
ukraine is being invaded by the russians
and apparently there were orders to
secure these bio labs at the very
beginning of the russian invasion
but the question is not is the united
states doing anything in these nations
right now the question is
have we been doing this in ukraine or in
georgia or in any other number of
countries around the world
for the average listener who doesn't pay
attention to to propaganda and to the
way that spokesmen speak
probably that's going to be good enough
but for people who know that these
statements are crafted with real
precision and specificity to me this
denial sounds sort of like an admission
because if if he could actually totally
deny the program i don't think he would
have cut off the reporter and use this
very particular present tense we are not
doing this right now at this very moment
i think he would have said this has
never happened this is completely bogus
forget about it
now
the fox news reporter jennifer griffin
did a slightly better job of trying to
answer this question because that's what
i said yesterday i said look i don't i
don't believe russian propaganda ever
russia has a long history of falsely
accusing the united states of using
bioweapons and then admitting actually
russia has admitted in private missives
that they sent for instance to mao
zedong that they falsely accuse the us
of bioweapons so i don't believe the
russian propaganda i don't believe the
chinese propaganda obviously but
likewise i am skeptical of the deep
state of my own government and so i
don't believe our propaganda either and
i want to get to the truth so jennifer
griffin at fox did a slightly better job
but not much
in terms of ukraine's bio labs which
have come under scrutiny tonight those
are soviet era bio labs that the u.s has
been engaged since 2005 in trying to
help ukraine convert the research
facilities safely in uzbekistan for
instance the united states eliminated
nearly 12 tons of weaponized anthrax
from an island in the aral sea in 2001.
here's a statement from the pentagon
quote on a daily basis russia propagates
either
either directly through state-run media
outlets or through the use of surrogates
disinformation aimed at btrps the u.s
bio-threat reduction programs laboratory
and capacity building efforts in former
soviet union countries the lugar center
in georgia and the central reference
laboratory in kazakhstan are the primary
targets but more recent disinformation
efforts have targeted laboratories in
ukraine through these different
disinformation campaigns russia falsely
claims the united states is developing
biological weapons in laboratories in
these countries as well as killing local
populations with purposeful release of
biological agents
okay so the official statement that
she's reading by the way she's not
reading her own reporting she's just
reading the handout that the pentagon
gave her
which is that's not reporting that's not
journalism that's just repeating talking
points from the people that you're
supposed to be investigating
but but the official statement is look
these are soviet era bio labs and the us
is just in there to help ukraine clean
them up and and
get rid of all the bio weapons
soviet union collapsed in 1991 how long
does it take to clean up a bio lab
we only began the program in 2005.
that's a pretty long time to wait to
clean up the soviet era bio weapons
laboratories okay 14 years but but even
since 2005 it's been 17 years how long
does it take to clean it up well now
some people are saying well okay
they weren't just cleaning up they're
trying to convert them they're
converting the labs
into ordinary scientific laboratories
where we're working on totally ordinary
normal things that have nothing to do
with weaponry or the military okay fair
enough then why is the military still
running it
why is that when you when you go to the
u.s embassy and kiev's website when you
go to their explainer on this program
they direct you to a dot mil website the
military all the funding for this
program comes from the pentagon
so look
we the u.s military does a lot of things
around the world to ensure the security
of the united states and global security
there are a lot of programs that are
secret that civilians
don't know about and many that they
really can't know about in order to
protect the integrity of the programs
that's fine
the russians have their thing the
chinese have their thing there's a lot
of secrecy a lot of people developing
lots of weapons and doing all sorts of
clandestine activities
but
but don't lie to me about it
don't because that's that's really
what's disrespectful here okay that's
really what's going to destroy the
credibility of our own government all
right the the government here has a lot
of answering to do and they're not doing
it they're just gaslighting us and
calling us all crazy kooks and
conspiracy theorists and russian puppets
i don't i don't think it's russian
puppetry to ask basic questions about
where our taxpayer dollars are going and
what sort of activities we're doing
around the world especially at a time of
global conflict that could frankly spur
world war iii there's the threat of
nuclear war we need to know what is the
actual circumstance of what's going on
that has led us to this point there's
nothing
there's nothing unpatriotic about that
it's extremely patriotic and and
extremely
rational
for a free country and a free people to
ask these questions of their own
government listen up guys
the daily wire is creating a universe of
woke free entertainment just for you
that means that we have your weekend
entertainment covered our latest movie
the hyperions debuted last night on our
dw premiere event i love the hyperions
this is
one of my favorite movies i've seen in
recent years i think it's just terrific
it's unlike anything you've ever seen
it's pure entertainment the way movies
are supposed to be
if you've not yet seen our first film
shut in it's got a score of 97 on rotten
tomatoes so make sure you go check that
out you can also watch the hyperions and
shut in right now coming soon gina
carano will be starring in daily wires
summer blockbuster terror on the prairie
for even more must-see weekend
entertainment on sunday you can watch
ben sit down with bill maher for his
sunday special it's bill maher unleashed
there will be no censorship or apologies
but wait there's more
we've got our documentaries like china
the enemy within a gripping five-part
series from the creator of the plot
against the president uh we've also got
our one-of-a-kind shows like a third
thursday book club candace debunked and
the search your membership makes all of
this possible when you join the daily
wire not only do you get great movies
documentaries or original shows you also
get investigative journalism that
fearlessly goes wherever the story does
so become a member go to dailywire.com
watch today help us build a universe of
news and entertainment that reflects
what you believe go to dailywire.com
watch today
speaking of war
there is some bad news for the west for
nato for the european union for ukraine
for the united states when it comes to
what's going on right now with russia in
eastern europe with this war in ukraine
the united states
has sent
kamala harris to go
and sort out the situation in eastern
europe
i am here
standing
here on the northern flank on the
eastern flank talking about what we have
in terms of the eastern flank and our
nato allies
and what is at stake at this very moment
she couldn't
she couldn't even get the flank right
they sent her to poland
uh which is very much not on the
northern part of nato that is on the
eastern part of nato she didn't know
where she was she did this this is a
similarity that kamala has with joe
biden
they don't know where they are they
don't know which end is up
the the
speech only got worse from there
kamala harris attempted to
to
rally the troops you know
you you once had ronald reagan show up
and say uh
you know mister he shows up to the
brandenburg gate mr gorbachev tear down
this wall you you once had uh uh winston
churchill speaking in america saying
from st
in the baltic to trieste in the adriatic
an iron curtain has descended upon
europe and and then
from kamala you get this
we all watched
the television coverage
of just yesterday that's on top of
everything else that we know and don't
know yet
based on what we've just been able to
see and because we've seen it or not
doesn't mean it hasn't happened
but just limited to what we have seen
i defy anyone to explain to me what that
meant
i defy anyone to try to translate that
gibberish into english you can't and
what i mean i mean this
i'm not really just joking about how
inept kamala harris is i mean this
sincerely
this is really bad news for ukraine
because it means that joe biden thinks
that ukraine has already lost
joe biden thinks that ukraine already
belongs to russia
because kamala harris is joe biden's
point person on failure
joe biden sends kamala harris to every
lost cause
to the southern border okay kamala's
going to be our point person on the
southern border now
that that's going to work out great
right this is an issue that's impossible
it's nothing's going to happen with it
and so here goes kamala how's that come
along has she fixed that i don't think
so he's sending her now every every
issue that he doesn't want to deal with
because he knows it's a lost cause
that's where he sends kamala so this is
unfortunate because
as of now
the russian invasion of ukraine has gone
much slower than a lot of people
predicted that it would the world has
rallied in a much more forceful way
against russia i think than putin
thought would happen there actually is a
chance for at least a negotiated piece
to maintain some semblance of ukrainian
sovereignty here
but you're not going to get that with
just abject weakness from joe biden and
you're not going to get that with kamala
harris showing up in warsaw to say we
know what we saw and we didn't see and
what we know we can do we can do if we
believe that we know that we can imagine
then we can do it here on the northern
side of nato in poland
you know you're definitely not going to
get it there i
putin already knows
that the
geopolitical strategy of the biden
administration is is confused to say the
the least
but if he now knows that they don't even
know where poland is uh you you're in a
really weak situation
you need strength not weakness speaking
of strength you know on this show
it has been set many people are talking
about it that uh sometimes we predict
the future so
yesterday or two days ago after ron
desantis endorsed this parental rights
and education bill
the ceo of disney
came out strongly against it begged
desantis do not sign this bill it's
terrible he was going to donate to stop
these bills around the country and i
said i can't wait for mack daddy
desantis to lay the political body slam
on this woke ceo this is going to look
great i don't think he's he's not going
to cave like asa hutchinson he's not
going to cave like kirstina and
christine before she reversed course
because it was sinking her political
career i said i think he's going to
stand firm governor desantis take it
away
the chance that i am going to
back down from my commitment to students
and back down from my commitment to
parents rights
simply because of fraudulent media
narratives or pressure from woke
corporations the chances of that are
zero
i also think that if you have companies
like a disney that are going to say and
criticize parents rights they're going
to criticize the fact
that we don't want transgenderism and
kindergarten and first grade classrooms
if that's the hill that they're going to
die on then how did they possibly
explain
lining their pockets with their
relationship from the communist party of
china
love it that's the answer and this is an
important lesson in leadership i don't i
don't just bring it up because it's very
satisfying to finally see a politician
smack down some woke ceo
this was a real political problem for
ron desantis ron desantis is the
government there's the governor rather
in florida
disney is a very big company in florida
disney world is a very important place
in florida so the ceo of disney
could cause a lot of problems for ron
desantis
and so there's a world in which rhonda
all what ron desantis wants to do is
keep his position and set himself up to
run for president simple as that and
there's a world i can i can understand
the thinking that would lead you to
believe okay well look
i can tick off all the other ceos disney
this could create a lot of problems all
right maybe i'll try to come to us
compromise and okay
it'll be that you can't teach radical
sexual education to
uh ch students
uh first grade through second grade but
kindergarten and third grade they're
still fine how about that we'll come
we'll split the baby we'll split the
baby down half will be boy half will be
girl we're gonna split the baby on
transgenderism maybe that'll do it no
that would
rather than
saving ron desantis political career in
florida in america
it would have completely destroyed it
the only argument for ron desantis for
governor and for president is this guy's
tough this guy's more got moral clarity
this guy's not going to back down the
second he gives an inch on something
like this he's dead in the water there's
no reason to elect him to anything
desantis knows that sometimes the best
defense is a good offense so he goes on
the offense
instead of i'm going to meet with the
disney ceo and i'm gonna shake his hand
and go
glad gladhand him and smile at him no
i'm gonna go out there and i'm gonna say
screw you
you're you're trying to abuse children
you you hate parents you i'm never gonna
back down defending parents you're a
monster i hate your guts and you can go
pound sand buddy
that's that's
not only a good offense not it's not
it's a good
defense too
because now you've got the disney ceo
back footed you've got him on his heels
what's he going to do he's probably
going to back off also because
the parents
are are on desantis's side
also because disney's supposed to be a
family company and the families are on
the side of ron desantis
it's a very small minority of families
or disney customers for the theme parks
and the movies and the merchandise it's
a very small percentage that support
radical transgender theory in first
grade
so what desantis has done is not tried
to just massage everything and make
everyone happy he just put himself in a
very strong position maybe joe biden
could learn a lesson from that maybe the
united states could start doing that on
the world stage rather than for instance
in ukraine
giving vladimir putin direct access to
the european oil market and hoping that
that keeps him happy enough not to
invade ukraine rather than literally
inviting him to invade just the eastern
part of ukraine and then hoping he'll
stop there
weakness is going to breed more violence
and chaos but if you have a little
strength if you
if you've got credible threats that is
going to breed a lot more peace and
you're seeing this by the way you're
seeing the florida model
the florida and virginia model on the
social issues on transgenderism on
critical race theory on on the social
issues
is is now being adopted
in a lot of other states georgia is now
adopting the don't say gay bill like a
parental rights and education bill idaho
is going even further than that
so
the absolutely wonderful great news
coming out of georgia is that george's
sb 613 bill
says quote no private or non-public
school or program to which this chapter
applies shall promote compel or
encourage classroom discussion of sexual
orientation or gender identity and
primary grade levels are in a manner
that is not appropriate for the age and
developmental stage of the student it's
almost point for point the the same as
the florida law
good stuff again
just for conservatives and republicans
broadly across the country
it's going to be a lot easier to get
these kind of totally common sense laws
put into place if a lot of states start
doing it if it's only florida then the
democrats and the libs and the radical
transgenderists are going to focus all
of their efforts on just killing it in
florida but if it pops up in florida and
georgia and idaho and all over the
country they're not going to be able to
aim all their their guns their
ideological and financial guns at
florida they're going to be spread out
you're going to have a lot better chance
of these laws remaining in place all
over the country idaho's done even
better idaho just voted to make transing
of the kids a felony
idaho's house just passed hb
hb675 really important to look into this
it was passed by vote of 55 to 13 so not
even close and it would make providing
they on the liberal side they call it
gender affirming care
to trans teens a felony with a life
sentence what does it really mean it
means pumping confused little kids full
of hormones and potentially mutilating
their genitals
it defines that as
child abuse and a felony with a
potential life sentence absolutely
well frankly a life sentence is a little
lenient if you ask me for
mutilating a poor little confused
child's body yeah i think that's
absolutely right this is more of what we
need to see
rather the way that conservatives have
run the cultural game for years is
always on the defensive we're always
negotiating against ourselves instead of
saying hey i want abortion banned it's
killing babies and it should be illegal
we say well
what if could we maybe just could we ban
it at 20 26 weeks would that be fine or
maybe 25 weeks and could no and then and
then that's where the overton window
sits that's where the negotiation begins
trump kind of showed us this with with
the art of the deal right you always ask
for
as much as you possibly can
as much as you can possibly credibly ask
for maybe you go even a little further
than that
and then wherever the negotiation ends
up is going to be much more favorable
toward you
great law being passed in idaho i want
to see more of that
in every conservative state in the
country i want to see that law being
passed the other side of the ideology is
just really weird and creepy okay and we
just
got a video of this of chasten jason is
pete budajudge's partner and he is uh
pretty outspoken obviously
on some of these social issues if you're
uh associated with mr buddage who
tries to make every single thing he's
doing every time he passes some mundane
regulation at the transportation
department he tries to make it seems
like like he's the most radical social
reformer in america and set himself up
for president well buddha judge's
partner jason
a clip just came out of him
running a gay camp
with bizarre
cultish overtones
all right i pledge my heart
[Applause]
with affirmation and equal rights for
awe
watch your head
and then he waves the rainbow flag this
stunt that he pulled
is extremely unpatriotic and extremely
sacrilegious
and i still find this guy more likeable
than pete buddha judge
somehow
because pete is just that unlikable but
what he did here is really it's really
unpatriotic you're you're asking
people to pledge their not just their
allegiance pledge their hearts
to the gay flag
he rewrites the pledge of allegiance to
the american flag and takes out the
american flag
and takes out god
and replaces under god with full of
pride not only the
deadly sin but the deadliest of the
seven deadly sins it's commonly been
called the queen of vice
now some people say it is the vice of
queens i don't know i don't know i've
just heard that it's quite an inversion
but he he says
that you you must pledge your heart
full of pride to the rainbow flag this
is a lot more than just a boy who likes
another boy
okay this is a lot more than just a
sexual desire
and even this is a lot more than even
pursuing a sexual desire that might be
unusual
this is a radical ideology
this is i've said it for a long time the
lgbt
elementopen it goes on and on
they're selling this to you
as though it were just a way to be nice
to people with sort of unusual sexual
desires
sex is almost secondary to the thing
it is a full-on
political cultural religious world view
that replaces america with your own
base desires and replaces god with pride
i mean it celebrates pride that's a
weird thing why don't why isn't it
you know celebrating
love why isn't it celebrating
individuality why pride why there's
there's always these sort of strange
religious overtones to it do you know
who unearthed the clip it wasn't some
homophobic
right wing
anti-gay it was the log cabin
republicans
it was the gay republican group
unearthed that clip because there were a
lot of guys a lot of guys who were
attracted to other guys who looked at
that and said whoa man whatever that is
i'm out
count me out of that please i don't want
to be
a part of that
the cultural battle that we are seeing
right now especially in these laws in
the schools in florida the the
rule in georgia and idaho this in
virginia for that matter with the
governor's race with glenn younkin the
two sides are
hey maybe don't trans the kids
and
chasen and pete buddha judge versus
chasing it right those are the two polls
it's hey let's not tell my
five-year-olds
that maybe he's actually a little girl
versus pledge your heart full of pride
to the rainbow flag huzzah huzzah
what do you think is gonna win what do
you think is more popular what do you
think is a more normal stable
attractive view of the individual and of
society i think
it's probably going to be
the don't trans the kids side of things
this is a full ideology but before we
get to the mailbag there's a
the democrats had to rush through their
last minute legislation last few days
because house democrats
had to make it to a retreat
to be entertained by a drag queen
not a joke this is being hosted by d
triple c chair sean maloney
the d triple c is the democrat
congressional campaign committee
this retreat they all ran off to
included a musical performance by a drag
queen named lady bunny lady bunny is
actually a pretty funny fella because
he's not just totally on board with the
democrats he's apparently made lots of
jokes about hillary clinton how terrible
she is and so i kind of as far as drag
queens go i kind of like lady bunny but
still
house members should not be going on
retreats to watch entertainment by drag
queens and then it got me thinking
what's the difference between a drag
queen and a transgender person
on the surface they're exactly the same
right men who identify as where pretend
to be women and dress up like women and
present themselves as women to the world
except one group knows that they're men
and the other group is pretending that
they're not men the difference is
self-awareness
the difference is one knows that they
are engaging in a kind of virtual
reality when they put on the lipstick
and the stilettos the other one believes
that virtual reality is real
they think that virtual reality that
what we're being sold are and our lives
are increasingly virtual right we
increasingly we're on we're spending our
lives scrolling increasingly we're
spending our lives on our computers
we're not increasing we can work from
home we don't need to be connected so
much to the physical world well that
that is the shift it's that
self-awareness and we're losing a lot of
that self-awareness we talk about
disinformation whether it's coming from
the pentagon whether it's coming from
the russians whether it's coming from
the chinese whether it's coming from
jesse smallett the the more detached you
are from the physical world
the easier it is to fall prey to that
kind of disinformation now we have got
to come back with my absolute favorite
time of the week that would be coming up
in the mailbag head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe right now we'll
be right back with a lot more
welcome back to the show my favorite
time of the week when i get to hear from
you in the mailbag first question up
from mike hello fellow name name-bearer
mike writes i am looking for some advice
on making decisions not what should i
have for dinner decisions but work or
life decisions i get into analysis
paralysis and have an extremely
difficult and emotional time deciding
i've heard all the platitudes just flip
a coin just
figure it out make a broncon list but
none of those things give me any clarity
when it comes to making a choice do you
have any advice to help decision making
to make it a little less painful
i'm with you i i am exactly the same way
i when i have to decide
i'll give you a great example i had i
was repainting my dining room
i
this process dragged on for months sweet
little elise and i were in disagreement
do we want green
no or do we want red as all dining rooms
should be painted so we're going back
and forth we're getting other people's
opinions i ask friends i ask
peoples whose aesthetic opinions i trust
we go on and on finally we decide red
then we've got to decide what red i get
a thousand swatches
not really a thousand i probably got i
don't know 20 or 30 swatches
none of the swatches worked i said no
we've got to get this watch we've got to
get this watch right at the very end i
was about to pick one and i heard about
a different kind of paint from a
different company i went we demand we
ordered another one we finally got that
one i said this i think is the perfect
one let's go with it
and it was the right color this took
months and months and months with some
decisions you can do that because it
doesn't really matter what color your
walls are painted and when you paint
them
some decisions are more urgent hey what
job am i going to take hey am i going to
get married hey
what even sort of what car am i going to
buy your car's breaking down you got to
pick a car
the
the way that i would
help you look if for some decisions take
your time who cares you know it doesn't
really matter but for the ones where you
really need to decide quickly
just know
that
as long as you're not doing something
immoral right as long as you're not
doing something unjust and they're both
sort of fine
you just have to pick because sometimes
indecision
is worse than the wrong decision
there's this poem by robert frost do you
know this is probably the most famous
poem by robert frost and it's completely
misunderstood the poem is too uh the
road not taken people think it's called
the road less traveled but it's not it's
called the road not taken poem goes uh
two roads diverged in a yellow wood and
sorry i could not travel both in b1
traveler long i stood and looked down
one as far as i could to where it bent
in the undergrowth then took the other
as just as fair and having perhaps the
better claim because it was grassy and
wanted wear though as for that the
passing there had worn them really about
the same and each that morning equally
laid and leaves no step had trodden
black
i kept the first for another day but
knowing how way leads onto why i doubted
that i should ever come back i shall be
telling us with a sigh somewhere ages
and ages hence two roads diverged in a
wooden eye i took the one less traveled
by and that has made all the difference
the people think this is why a poem
about individuality and how you have to
go do your own thing and the thing that
most people aren't doing it's not
there is no road less traveled by in the
poem there they equally lay and leaves
no step in trod and black they're about
equally traveled
he just picked one
and then he later on was longing and
thinking about the decision that he
didn't make
and then he creates this narrative for
himself about how it was so important to
make the decision that he did make but
it was it was just
chance it was just fortune it was just
life he just made a decision and so i
hate to come back to that first
bit of advice there but when it comes to
urgent matters where you actually need
to move on and you can't wait to paint
your room for six months
just make the decision and somewhere
ages and ages hence you can say with a
sigh i took the road less traveled by
and that has made all the difference
from teagan
hey michael me and my wife were
discussing the recent phenomenon of
women not taking the last name of their
husband after marriage they keep their
maiden name the reason for this is
because they want to break tradition
fight against the patriarchy and keep
their own identity my question is how do
i explain why it's important for women
to take the last name of the man after
they get married with your famous wisdom
you're the reason i subscribe to the
daily wire thanks for all the work you
do
here's how you explain it to them
ask these women where they got their
last name
or
they got their last name from their
fathers
the patriarchy wins again
now maybe you're talking to a really
young woman a zoomer who's lived in
political correctness and is several
generations in now to this kind of woke
politically correct world
maybe she got her last name from her
mother i don't know it's rare but it
happens
ask that young woman where her mother
got her last name
from
her mother's father because the
patriarchy wins in the end the decision
is not between
becoming subservient to the man and girl
power when you're deciding whether to
keep alas your maiden name or to
take on your husband's name
either way you've got a man's name the
question is are am i going to identify
primarily in
this new family that i am creating
through my marriage or am i going to
identify primarily by my old family
before the marriage
and what does that say about the
marriage and the family that i am in
now
that's the question
a lot of people get tricked into this by
feminism feminism is very wily but
it's really pretty simple
you're not you're not choosing between
me the girl power or my husband you're
just deciding okay
who who do i identify with more my
husband or my daddy from jen hey michael
or shall i say nostradamus thank you i
love that you've become the love guru of
the daily wire
my question is about being friends with
someone who shut down a romantic
relationship but kind of offered
friendship instead
is it ever worth it to be friends with
someone that you have a crush on though
it is unrequited especially if you
weren't friends before but enjoyed
hanging out with them
thanks and praying i won't have to
settle like you slightly hint that women
of a certain age should do
maybe
i'm not saying it's impossible and maybe
you and he
really hit it off in some platonic way
and you'll enjoy playing bridge together
and never long for anything more
but if you are a single woman
you're interested in this guy
romantically you're saying that you're
you're i think you're implying in your
question that you want to settle down
and get married and start a family
why would you waste your time on
this guy who's not interested in you
well the only reason would be because
you think that you can persuade him to
be interested in you romantically in the
long run and maybe you can and maybe you
can but that's that's kind of that's
quite the gamble
you don't have infinite time as you're
probably working or studying
you you know you've got other
commitments in your life you've got
other people to see and so
in those precious few hours that you
have to yourself where you can
look toward
finding a boyfriend or fiance or husband
or settling down
why would you waste it on some dude who
says no i just i pretty much just want
to play pinocchio with you forever until
we go our separate ways
i wouldn't do that i probably would not
do that i'd go i'd go find a hunk if i
were you
from andrew michael always enjoy your
show thanks for doing what you do
another dating and relationship question
why not
how many dates should i give someone
before deciding there isn't really any
chemistry and moving on i tend to go on
at least two or three but most of the
time the more i get to know a girl the
less interesting and attractive she
seems to me never a good sign having
said that
i also recently turned 36 so i also
can't discount that i'm the problem too
picky unrealistic expectations etc my
general thinking was that attraction
should be something that grows naturally
but do you think that i'm not giving
women enough of a shot for a
relationship to develop signed the
crotchety millennial
probably you are the problem
and potentially the places you're
looking to find women
are a problem too
you say that you become consistently
less attracted to these women
that's probably because what is
attracting you in them is not really in
them it's not really love it's a sort of
infatuation
it's just a hologram that you are super
imposing over these women which is your
own
fantasy of what a woman should be
and i don't know why that is
lots of different behavior dating lots
of women can do that looking at porn can
do that creates unrealistic expectations
reading certain books or can do that too
but then when you get to know the actual
woman you like them less and less and
less so i would
i'm not here to just to scold you you
should figure out what it is that is not
attractive about these women to you
and then stop seeking out women who have
those qualities
there are plenty of women that i know
who
physically are very attractive where i
think i'd probably
you know take a walk to the rickety
stool store if we ever ended up getting
married because i just i couldn't i just
couldn't bear it you know we're just not
compatible okay we don't really go
together very well uh
so don't pursue those women
are you meeting those women in bars well
then stop meeting women in bars maybe
try to find a woman
through a mutual friend through a family
member through a friend of a colleague
maybe you meet this woman in church
maybe i don't know whatever but
clearly you are doing something wrong if
you if you've made it this far and you
still find these women unattractive then
something not just not about you
necessarily but about your strategy is
wrong okay and also i would when you
find a woman to go on a date maybe
you're going on too many dates for that
matter
women are not just cheap disposable
things and or swiping right culture it's
very easy to think of them that way
maybe you're
getting a little too frisky too soon
with some of these women and so it's
more it's easier to see them merely as
vessels for your pleasure rather than
actual dignified creatures made in the
image of god with whom you could share
your life and become one flesh so
if that is the case
perhaps wait to go on a date until you
find a woman
who actually
has a quality about her that you find
attractive
and is not merely a convenient way to
spend a wednesday or thursday night from
jake hello one who sees the future and
turns it into an ad segue in my friend
group there have been more and more
debates regarding porn
specifically only fans
there was an article saying that one in
five women in new york are considering
doing it to pay rent oh my goodness
uh they all said the typical it's their
body so is their choice or as long as
she is not being forced to it's fine
just don't watch it if you don't like
porn when we are debating it how can i
as a conservative destroy these fools
with facts and references to cardinal
manning thanks very much
oh well you just say it's wrong
the whole my body my choice thing is
just fake you don't have the right to do
whatever you want to your body
everyone understood this in america
until about five minutes ago this is why
we have laws against drugs
not even just laws against driving while
on drugs or being in public while on
drugs we also have laws against those
things but we also have laws just
against possessing certain drugs because
you do not have total autonomy to do
whatever you want with your own body
suicide is against the law
in a lot of places actually in some
places it's legal now but traditionally
it's against the law why because you
don't have the right to do whatever you
want with your own body because you
don't have the right to do things that
are wrong
and it's wrong
to
sell yourself like you're just a meat
puppet and it's wrong to
consume those sorts of things and to
trade in those sorts of things and we
still have laws against all of that in
this country and they're
enforced
sometimes and other times they're not
enforced but it's just it's not good for
these women well they need it to make
money no they don't no they don't i know
look i'm a new yorker new york's a very
expensive place i know it takes a lot of
hustle to make it there you don't need
to sell your body you don't need to
become a prostitute to make it there and
if you do move to brooklyn okay if you
do hoboken is really nice
it's not worth it it's really not worth
it it's going to really mess up your
life it's going to mess up your
relationships it's going to mess up your
sense of yourself
do not
do not it's not worth it so that you can
have that really nice 500 square foot
studio apartment in
hell's kitchen okay i promise you
probably you're not even going to afford
that you're probably going to afford a
small one-bedroom apartment with like
four roommates okay
that glitz that dream ain't worth it how
do you how do you convince people that
it's wrong to treat their bodies like
they're just purely flesh because you're
not purely flesh because we're talking
because we have reason because we can
communicate because we have longings and
loves and desires and joys because we're
more than our bodies we're also our
souls and we need to make sense of that
too i'm michael knowles this the michael
knowles show see you on monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin